speaking of cults
right-wing commentator Anna Perez says
she'd be willing to take a bullet for
Trump and that Trump would be willing to
take a bullet for her this is
interesting on a few different levels
let's take a listen to it uh something
that really kind of inspired me before I
did this show uh was hearing Ryan what
Ryan said in the episode that he did
today right before this he said I would
take a bullet for president Trump and
when he said that at first I was a
little taken aback I was like all right
Ryan that's a little that's a little
much but then I thought about it for a
split second and then I realized no it's
not you know why because president Trump
would take a bullet for me president
Trump is taking a bullet for me
president Trump is prepared to take a
bullet for all of us
and of course that is not true so let's
talk about a couple different things
here first of all it's funny to me that
these Trump supporters still think Trump
cares about them it's it's so abundantly
apparent now Beyond any question that
Trump does not like his supporters Trump
has spent his entire life as a rich guy
from New York City trying to stay away
from folks that are like the vast
majority of those who support him that's
first of Trump would not take a bullet
for anyone remember when Trump said he
would have run into the building where
there was a shooter no he would not so
so they are wrongly assessing that Trump
cares about them
but this is a great reminder about
cult-like traits you've got your leader
who demands complete loyalty and
obedience from their followers Trump
fits that description perfectly during
the presidency since leaving office he
demands every follower must always
remain loyal above all else he'll use
fear he'll use intimidation to keep him
in line and when they go off script
Trump instantly abandons them another
sign of occult is using propaganda
techniques to manipulate your followers
and again Trump does it he lies all the
time to his followers and says don't
believe what you're hearing and seeing
simply believe what I tell you and if
anyone criticizes me you know they're
lying and they're trying to deceive you
and the followers buy it and they go wow
this person criticized Trump let's go
and attack that person it's blind
cult Behavior Cults also do the US
versus them thing if you're not part of
the group you're part of the enemy
you're either with us or against us and
this is something that is super common
with Trump supporters if you disagree
with them you're demonized you're fake
news news article adversarial to Trump
fake news
political view different than Trump's
Un-American Marxist communist and it's a
sort of extreme tribalism extreme
tribalism and it is very cult-like and
then the other thing I think is
important to mention
is that Cults often will require members
require it'll just happen over time to
kind of give up their own identities and
to conform to the beliefs and the
practices and sometimes even the
physical appearance and the slang and
the ideology the physical you know the
the clothing Etc of the cult and Trump
supporters have shown that as well and
it's not just literally the red Mega
hats it's the adopting these irrational
beliefs embracing conspiracy theories
simply because this is what the group
now believes rejecting science
threatening violence in defense of their
beliefs so all of the warning signs are
clear this is a cult Anna Perez embodies
that blind loyalty propaganda Us Versus
Them willingness to give up your own
identity and we need to Simply call it
out to prevent others from falling in I
don't know that I can save Anna Perez I
I really don't but maybe we can prevent
someone else from falling into this
Insanity one of our sponsors is paired
the app for couples every day pair word
gives you and your partner questions
quizzes games to have fun to stay
connected to deepen your conversations
and get to know each other better what's
great about it is you don't even have to
be in the same room especially with the
baby right now my girlfriend and I are
quite busy and paired really helped us
to stay connected you get a daily
question to answer you can't see your
partner's answer until you answer
yourself and their questions about
everything relationship life intimacy
other things and all of the exercises
were developed by academic psychologists
and expert relationship therapists as
well questions like what makes you feel
lucky in your relationship great when
you want to remember and have gratitude
a really great thing what's an activity
you could try together this month
actually gets people thinking about
things to do it can go in really funny
directions as well but it just always
feels like time well spent head over to
paired.com Pacman for a seven day free
try trial and 25 off a subscription the
link is down below